GOT TO GET  A BIG ONLEY.
>>UNCES IT
BACK TO WEND OUT.
>> David: TRYING TO N THIS ROAD.
WATCH AYO OUT HERE WAIT FOR HIM
AND GET UP OR GET O O A PLATTER.
COULDN'T GET THE LAYUP.
HE SPENT THREE YEARS WITH THE
CELTIC'S, GOT HIS FIRST START,
GOT
STOP. GAME.
ITS -- --
>> Matt: JUST HUNGRY, RIGHT?
WASHINGTON WITHOUT BEAL TO EVEN
MAC IT INTO THE PLAY-IN.
DUNKS.  WE ARE SHOWING THE GRE
ASSISTS.
>> K COMMUNICATOR, AND
RIGHT PICKED.
HAMIDOU DIALLO WITH A THREE DOWN
AFTER THE
DECISIONS AT THE TO
HERE'S  KUMING
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
LOOKS FROM COBY WHITE.
WORD. ANTETOKOUNMPO.
SWITCH.
WESTBROOK, DRIVIV
DETERMINE THE SOBER.
>> Ryan: THERE IS SIAKAM.
UNIQUE HE AND HIS GAME ARE.
>> Kate: THE OFFENSIVE